so brady
one of my favorite subjects after
football obviously is um as you know is
black holes
and there's over the last sort of six
months or so there's been some quite big
black hole news and i think it's time to
um let me share it with you go i'm all
ears what's going on so so as you know i
mean this there's been a problem that's
kind of been around my my entire life
basically and it's the the famous black
hole information paradox
uh which so hawking first sort of
proposed it around the time i was born
about about uh well should i say how
long ago mid-seventies it was um
and
so hawking spent his whole life
trying to solve this problem never quite
managed it well it seems that in the
last year or so
uh we i think we're there i think it's
been solved
what is the problem in very in a
nutshell it's that black holes seem to
lose information they seem to have sort
of information seems to disappear inside
black holes
and and that kind of breaks
fundamentally the laws of quantum
mechanics quantum mechanics basically
tells you that um you can't lose
information what goes in must come out
so hawking proposed that he seemed to
see evidence that black holes were
actually losing this information and he
figured well that means they're breaking
quantum mechanics this is like sacrilege
tony when a physicist says information
what do they mean you don't mean like
three bottles of milk or the the
liverpool game will score was three two
like what is information
i can absolutely mean that so let me
give you an example i've actually come
prepared with an example so obviously
we're going to talk about information
what we really want to talk about is is
in the context of entropy
so um during lockdown i've been
homeschooling my kids
and we've been doing some experiments
and i'm not very much i'm not very good
experimentalist i'm no feel more reality
right um but we've been trying a few one
of the ones we did was we um balancing
liquids of different density on top of
one another can you see that brady i've
got a liquid there i've got the blue
liquid on top of the the red liquid and
then the other one it's the other way
around you can't quite see it as well
but the red liquid is on top
okay so
we've got two different liquids they
look very different right these two
liquids they look very different and you
would say they're completely different
states
but what i can do is of course i can
stir the liquid
right
and i can stare the other one
right
and now if i show you them
you can't tell the difference between
those guys right they look exactly the
same you can't tell whether this one was
the one that had the blue on top or this
one was the one that had the blue on top
it's impossible to tell right just by
looking at it so the measurements that
you're doing just by staring at this
thing it could be either state that
created it could have been the one with
the red on top but it could be the one
in the blue on top there could be lots
of other ways you could have created
that same sort of gunky mess right and
that gives it entropy it's like an
uncertainty a sort of missing
information
uh stuff you don't know
just by based on the measurements that
you're doing of this object similarly
you know you have a sort of a set of
headphones that are all tangled there
could have been loads of different ways
they could have gotten to that roughly
tangled state and that gives this
entropy
in some sense some missing information
now of course in the case of this this
liquid i could sort of dive inside and
unpick the microscopic structure of the
whole thing and extract the information
out of whether it was blue on top of the
start or red on top i could in principle
get that out of here so you're talking
about almost like doing the ultimate
crime scene investigation and unpicking
this came from that direction and this
came from that direction and figuring
out all this stuff to say oh it was red
and blue at the start totally you could
do that in the case of that that the
case of this thing right in the case of
a black hole however it really does hide
the information because you can't get
anything out of a black hole you can't
go in and unpick the information and
feed it to the outside
so
to see how black holes do carry entropy
like let me
imagine a scenario right suppose you
wake up one morning and there's a black
hole at the bottom of your garden right
and okay it's quite alarming and
probably it's going to sort of tear you
apart but it's sort of tidal effects if
you get too close to it but let's say
you don't get too close and the next day
uh you wake up again the black hole is
still there but it's grown by say the
mass of an elephant
okay now how do you know that it
swallowed an elephant
did it swallow an elephant or maybe did
it swallow a car with the same mass or
something else with the same mass
there's no way that you can know right
because when you do a sort of
measurement on a black hole the only
things that you can measure are its mass
its charge and its angular momentum
so there's literally no way you can tell
whether it was made by an elephant or
made by a car there's no measurement you
can do on that black hole that will tell
you that it will look the same tony
why is this not just a problem of access
to the information rather than the
existence of the information brilliant
question brady okay so if that was all i
told you then you'd say yes that's it's
just hidden behind the black hole if i
dived inside i'd find that information
everything would be fine it'd be no
problem okay great the trouble is
hawking then told us that black holes
actually radiate
that they'll evaporate okay so you have
this process by which you think of pairs
of particles being produced near the
event horizon and those particles one
particle due to the insertion principle
might find itself just outside one just
inside the outside guy escapes the
inside guy falls in
and this black hole evaporates it starts
to lose its mass that radiation that it
produces
it's really completely random in some
sense so so you know at the event
horizon where this all this magic's
happening you know
there's not you know it could be this
particular went out or it could be the
other one that went out it's totally
random the only thing that the the
radiation sees is the shape of the space
time the geometry of the space time from
that radiation you can't extract that
there was it was made from a car that
black hole was made from a car or that
it was made from an elephant you can't
get that from the radiation
and then eventually the black hole
evaporates away completely and all
you're left with is the radiation
okay which i've just said and hawking
told us doesn't contain the information
that you need so the information's
disappeared which is disaster for
quantum mechanics i've got one more
uh
half-baked brady theory as to how you
could find that the information
when i woke up on the second morning and
the black hole is heavier could i not do
a census of everything outside the black
hole and say oh there's one less
elephant in the solar system it must be
an elephant that fell in
um
no
no
okay if you have two regions of space
that are separated from one another if
you have a pure quantum state over the
whole space
right
then
and then you separate them the two
regions there could be information in
this region
which relies on knowledge of this region
and vice versa okay so if you separate
the two regions you can have missing
information in this and missing
information in this
but they kind of compensate for one
another they account for one another
which is kind of what you're asking
can i do that
and that ought to be what happens that
absolutely ought to be what happens but
hawke's calculations suggested that it's
not what happens
okay so it's fair it's a fair point what
you said yes isn't the information just
can i just sort of account for the
missing information on one side versus
the other side and everything takes care
of itself
that's what quantum mechanics demands
that it should be able to do in some
sense
hawking said well here's the calculation
show me how it's done i can't do it all
right then so let's let's not get too
bogged down and all my stupid questions
let's talk about what's actually
happened what's the news what's been
happening recently that's got you
excited okay so before can i get to that
i'm going to tell you about hawking's
bet okay so hawking spent his his whole
life trying to solve this problem okay
and he was convinced first time that uh
information was lost inside black holes
and he had a him and kip thorne who you
probably know from the film interstellar
had a bet with um
uh preschool from caltech over whether
information was lost or not so hawking
and thorne said said that it it would be
lost preschool said no no no no don't be
silly quantum mechanics is too precious
no way it's been lost it's going to get
lost it'll be it'll survive somehow this
information so hawking then spent a lot
of time trying to figure out one way or
another then became convinced it
probably was survived but couldn't work
out how came up with some ideas how to
the point where he ended up paying the
out the bet to preschool kip thorne
though thought that hawking's ideas
weren't quite right i mean you refused
to pay the bet um it turns out hawking's
ideas weren't right
um but over the years people have become
convinced that information was
uh
you know it wasn't lost
but not really sure how it how it wasn't
lost if you see what i mean so then yeah
right what's the news
we seem to have figured out how it's not
lost okay
so
so information is preserved so this
breakthrough has come from from two
teams one on the east coast of america
uh centered around princeton and one one
around stamford on the west coast so the
princeton team did a really nice review
just last week actually where they gave
a really nice analogy for how how this
information is is is preserved okay so
the story goes you have um
you have some some followers he's he
lives in a in a posh house and it's full
of beautiful
extremely valuable paintings okay so
he's um but he has no money
okay so but he wants so he wants to show
off his show off his wealth but he has
no cash he's just got these paintings
he's really valuable paintings so he
says okay then i'm gonna borrow some
money off the people of the town
okay so he says right borrow some money
off the people at town get some cash
that way
and
says he he'll use the paintings as a
guarantee
okay
so um he does that he gets this cash and
he throws lavish parties
the people of the town meanwhile they no
longer have any cash because they've
lent it all to the guy in the house
okay so they're certainly not throwing
lavish parties they're living very
frugally so you look at this from the
outside and you say well who's who's um
who's the guys the townspeople seem
quite poor here right they don't seem
very rich but of course that's not true
they are rich
they kind of because they you know they
they kind of own in a sense those
paintings that are locked inside the
house they're their paintings
right and this is analogous to what's
happening with the black hole so in the
analogy the house is the black hole
okay the town's people are like the
radiation
and the um
the wealth of the towns people is the
quantum information that's stored in
that radiation
so very naively you look at this and you
think that the townspeople are poor or
that the radiation has not doesn't have
much quantum information but actually it
does
okay it's somehow got access to the
interior of the black hole in the case
of the analogy the the um
the sort of townspeople actually have
much more wealth and you can secretly
see that by looking at maybe the record
of the loan the record of the loan will
show that they have some connection with
the with the inside of the house
it's my elephant all over again of
course it had to be the it had to be
right but now let's see how it happened
this is great this is this is where it
gets beautiful how does that play out in
the black hole case
okay how does the radiation make that
connection
to the interior of the black hole that
that it seems like you shouldn't be
allowed that right because this is
violating locality and space and time
but what happens is the following
there's an island forms inside the black
hole
kind of a sort of region inside the
black hole they call it the island
and that kind of you start to think of
that not as part of the black hole but
was part of the radiation itself
the radiation makes a connection to this
island
through a wormhole i love wormholes
right that's how it makes it so how do
you how does the information leak out
well what you would do is you would do
some complicated um
sort of measurement and it can be
exponentially complicated right
measurements on the on the hawking
radiation right and effectively you're
creating this wormhole which then
accesses the interior of the black hole
and you can get the information out you
can figure out whether it was made from
an elephant
or a car
now these wormholes
they're really hard to produce you
absolutely cannot produce them at all
until the black hole is radiated away
roughly half its size okay it's past
this time called the page time
but after that you can start to create
them and it gets easier to create them
and actually these these guys have shown
that
in some simple toy models of gravity
that these wormholes are there and
actually they dominate the behavior at
late times and
hawking never knew about them and that's
why he made the wrong conclusion
to go back to the painting analogy
you told you told me
when a black hole radiates hawking
radiation it's a random act there's no
control over what particles will happen
to form on one side of the event horizon
or the other and that's why information
perhaps was being lost
and if we're going to attach that to the
analogy of our rich painting owner
surely the problem here is
there's no control over whether he's
going to pay back the loan pay back the
guarantee because the money coming back
out to the townspeople has now been
randomized
right okay and and here is the it is
difficult to get the information out of
the black hole and it might be very
difficult
to get the money back from the from the
townsperson like the door's locked you
know you know set up a barricade but
it's not impossible
okay it's there okay it's there and and
so the way they and the guys outside can
prove their wealth they say look here's
the document here it is i made this loan
if you're looking at black hole
you need to create this wormhole to get
in so tony if we were creating a very
very fantasy situation here and i was
going to give you
infinite uh tools and measurement
devices and spaceships and all the
things you could possibly want right and
i said all right i'm gonna send you out
to that black hole somewhere in the
universe
tell me what went down get the
information back for me all right i want
to know the story
what are you doing are you looking for
like are you looking for a wormhole is
the wormhole near the black hole what
like how would you
go about this investigation yeah so it's
really so that's really really difficult
um so firstly
if the black hole hasn't radiated enough
of its of its size away
then you can't do it at all it's just
impossible to get the information out
if it's gone past the 7.0 so you know
you've gone past a certain stage past
this page time then then indeed you can
um
but it's it's exponentially difficult uh
to do and it gets it gets easier and
easier but but it's still really really
hard to unpick that to do you basically
have to do a quantum measurement of the
radiation and you're trying to sort of
uh extract um the nature of the state
um but it's really really difficult you
know maybe in terms of practical
purposes may be impossible but that
doesn't matter the point is is in
principle is it possible
and it is possible and they showed that
these wormholes do actually dominate in
this in principle scenario are you using
the wormhole to go inside the black hole
and make measurements or measuring what
comes out of the worm so we're going to
be really really precise about it the
way you can think of it is is the
following so the radiation um
you know naively contains all this
missing information it's it's what we
call a mixed state in quantum mechanics
it seems very impure in a sense uh all
this missing all these missing
ingredients what the wormhole does it
connects it with particles that were
once entangled with it
and that purifies the state so the
wormhole literally enables you to purify
the radiation so so you've got all this
stuff which is all random over here it
used to be connected to stuff that was
over here right but now it's been
disconnected but actually the wormhole
reconnects them and purifies the quantum
state and so you actually it has all you
doesn't have any doesn't have the
missing information that you thought it
had
tony is this breakthrough a situation
whereby
it's like a new discovery and an advance
that could be used to you know
understand things better and
maybe do things in the future or is this
more just a case of we've found a
theoretical loophole that means the
current system we're clinging to still
works so don't worry there's no
exception go about your business i think
that's a really interesting question
because i think i think one of the
things about the black hole information
products that people always said was the
black hole in the information process is
so profound it's so incredible
that when we solve it and i'm gonna say
that i think we have solved it okay that
when we solve it it will reveal
something
dramatic about space and time that's
it'll say something about quantum
gravity something like that right
now i don't think that's happened and
the reason is is it so so hawking
himself could have actually got this
solution without any knowledge of
quantum gravity it doesn't rely on
quantum gravity one of the great ideas
that came from looking at the
information products was this idea of
holography uh you know that that um that
actually the information is stored on
the boundary of space-time you know that
you know you can basically describe
gravity by some
stuff on the boundary of space time
and that come and that was certainly an
inspiration for these ideas but it
doesn't rely on it it doesn't rely on it
you didn't need any of that so it it in
a way it's that makes it beautifully
simple the solution and makes it feel
right
but where's the amazing new insight that
we were promised well we don't know
maybe it's very early days yet um there
is a little strange thing going on
that's sitting in there which is this
this idea that um there's almost like a
randomness
uh to quantity suggest there might be a
randomness to quantum gravity that
when you talk about quantum gravity
maybe the theory isn't um just one
theory it might be like what we call an
ensemble of theories the theories itself
there's a little sort of technical
subtlety in there in terms of the kind
of theories they they played with
to solve this a theory is called jt
gravity
which have this property but is that
something that you're gonna need for the
to sort of extend it to sort of full
four dimensional general relativity and
so on maybe
um
we don't know that might be the sort of
little smoking gun that's saying ah
that's the really
that's the nugget that's going to take
us to give us that sort of you know what
we were promised uh from the from a
solution to the information paradox when
you look through what they've published
and what they've discovered
what
what do you think the leap or the clever
thing they thought of was that all the
men and women before didn't think of
like what's the thing you'd look at and
go
ah
yes clever i see what you did as ever
it's not just one thing right i've
talked about i mentioned the holographic
principle the idea that all this that
you can describe gravity with a theory
on the boundary of the space time that's
clearly been a major inspiration a major
ingredient in terms of understanding in
the end we didn't need it but in getting
there in the journey it was crucially
important
um there was a new way of thinking about
entropy which was came from these guys
ryo and takanagi um
that was really important but actually i
want to highlight the contribution of of
one guy in particular who's um is a
young english guy i'm not just saying
that because i'm biased straight um but
he's a he's actually just a phd student
at stanford but actually his work
this guy called jeff pennington his work
um that he did some of it she did on his
own was really sort of a prelim to a lot
of this and then he's now on the papers
with the that finally seems to have
solved it
but is the work he was doing before
seems to be really really important as
well so in a way it's like the new kid
on the blocks just finally sent
everybody over the line
and um
i i think we've got an absolute star in
the making there if i'm honest um and
funnily enough i was
uh so i had some discussions with him
and uh turns out he
he lived around the corner from from
where emma watson went to school you
know watson who plays hermione in a in
the harry potter films uh i think that
this sister's mate his sister may have
hung around in a similar circle or
something but it sort of makes me laugh
it's like did she know there was a real
wizard
actually living just around the corner
you mentioned that wormholes have been a
key part of this
what is a wormhole i always thought a
wormhole somewhere where like you know
you put your hand in the hole here in on
earth and it comes out on the other side
of the universe or something they're
like these like ultimate shortcuts
am i right or are they something a bit
more technical that's exactly what it is
of course if we're going to be brutally
honest um these calculations are not
really done in space time they're done
in space space you actually flip turn
time into an imaginary time that's how
you do these calculations so these are
really
wormholes in those scenarios
um it's a sign of technical detail that
i i don't want to get bogged down in um
but yeah it's exactly you would normally
think of a space-time wormhole at least
there's something like that something
that connects two regions of space in
these calculations it's connecting two
reasons of space but there is no time in
these setups because you've gone to
imaginary time um but yeah that's that's
that's that's exactly what they are
imaginary time thanks for dropping that
bombshell right at the end
well there's all these details right you
know i said i spent two days trying to
pick them
the extra dimensions angle okay so the
difference between those sorts of black
holes the astrophysical black holes and
the kind that you might produce the lhc
are those are those are very large
they're very large black holes okay
they've been formed from stellar
collapse you know death of a star
collapses and forms a black hole